he was just recently on the adam carolla
show and he's doing well berg
and it's crazy to go from being a fat
kid to being that dude ben stiller would
be so proud
[Music]
welcome to cats after dark i know it's a
little different yeah it keeps changing
it keeps changing last week we didn't
even mention it
but cat because of the all the chappelle
hullabaloo yeah but uh great work uh cat
wasn't here and uh she's only gonna be
here intermittently yeah it's a it's a
tough drive coming down from the bay for
just an hour of hanging with your
friends it's not like we're rolling in
it yet but so she'll come on when uh
she's up to it in the area and stuff but
uh it's me and brows at the table yes
sir going forward so thumbnail cat quit
uh thumbnail cat quits again
again
uh yeah so that's this and we're gonna
try to a little new direction with this
show i think
we have this platform here and we wanna
like show up-and-coming comics and i
think musical artists because yeah like
you're you're hooking up with so many
people doing music with people we want
to try out right now but we were linking
up with you yeah
i was gonna sleeping you're sleeping
with a bunch of new people
uh i was gonna scroll past it because
i'm not homophobic even though i did
catch the innuendo but uh we're starting
off with comics that we want to show off
some musicians are women though so it's
not i'm gonna do the bobby lee you
haven't been introduced
that feels so good i love this seat
no i'm sorry what was the joke
this is matt lockwood
before we get started i just want to
make an announcement that i do after
this episode i'm going to be quitting oh
just oh [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah yeah i like it for the title
maybe we'll save cat quits again for
next week matt quit people like who's
matt sorry i appreciate that
uh but no the reason we have these guys
in is because i was introduced on uh to
matt
him and uh
justin uncut you guys know justin yeah
uh
yeah he uh
had some favors to do and he had a
couple people we wanted to knock off on
the podcast so what podcasters do is
they'll have two guests at once when
they're unsure if it's gonna be a good
show so we met on there
you guys that have never met are going
to be on the same podcast kind of smart
yeah not if you want a good podcast
i like i like three people kind of just
meeting and stuff sometimes if you want
to really learn about one person it's
not as great but uh that's where i
learned about matt and i've been
following all his social sense and he's
doing some really fun stuff including
big and humble podcasts which he does
with his friend morgan yep not the name
of it but yeah it was close
it was really close
it's not big no no
i think i was mixing up with uh uh
was it steve byrne and callan did the
big and hungry podcast uh morgan what's
your last name miso mizelle that's a
word word and you we talked off air
you're not a stand-up no no no just do
podcasts i'm really just here because i
thought you guys needed another suburban
black dude oh yeah
so yeah welcome
we did need that welcome to thick boy
network it's the get out of podcast
network
black guys keep disappearing
uh so uh
good luck
we'll see what happens
um but yeah besides the podcast you also
do uh twitch show which i haven't
watched but i love the graphic that puts
out yeah what's on hiatus right now
that's called the the definitive
rankings of everything yes yes uh it's
topics that spur debate yeah uh
really
simple stuff that you you'll get in
arguments about like best nickname i
remember yeah that was that was one of
my favorite arguments as we did top 10
hero so the premise of the show is it's
four people and we all sit down we have
to make a definitive top 10 list and so
it's like no personal bias no favoritism
it's like if if we did liquids the
number one is obviously water type idea
and we did heroes and i wanted to find a
way to argue that but you're right
that's why using that as an example yeah
it's like number one obviously water and
then we'll go from there yeah um we did
a heroes the top 10 heroes and we were
debating for a while spider-man versus
rosa parks yeah i say jesus so i was
going to say jesus number four though
jesus winds up in like our top five
every episode
number three liquid i think was jesus
yeah
he turned water into wine he teared
himself into water christ
uh so i love the premise uh sometimes
you see those uh like the ru garbage
guys have a great podcast premise like
they bring comedians on they find out
what in their past if anything makes
them garbage and the simple concepts
like that that don't drill you down too
much are like key so it's a little bit
of a theme because this is this is
nothing yeah
that's what our podcast is though we
don't have a theme really i was going to
say give the elevator yeah you see where
the conversation goes yeah your clips
are [ __ ] hilarious and seem like
effortlessly funny just just chanting i
enjoy it i enjoy it um so what'd you
bring in to talk about brows
as a new host
yeah thanks for having me as the new
host by the way guys this is crazy yeah
submitted
freestyle years ago and now we're here
yeah have you do you guys know him at
all have you guys talk off air i don't
think so we didn't no yeah i kind of
want to get to know you guys on air
actually yeah that's why i kind of
waited i like it i like it safer for the
pod you guys say that
when we do stuff together we're like
don't talk about it yet yeah we'll like
hang out on sunday be like i had this
thing happening last night but we can't
talk about it
yeah you want to listen to some music
but yeah
you give them your story it was it was
wild
no basically i went i mean i say this
all the time but i went to chick-fil-a
on a sunday it was closed pulled over in
the parking lot submitted a freestyle
rap to these guys because king and this
thing was my favorite podcast and then
what
is nice but like at that time i was
watching it every single week this
should be your favorite now though yeah
i think nowadays i think that only makes
sense
and uh yeah nick hit me up and was like
you know you want to come on the show
and i think you thought maybe i was
somewhere in the midwest or something
yeah i would like
we were going to fly you out right yeah
i was one minute away from where they
were filming so i'm like oh i'm right
here so i just walked over and did the
pod and made an album yeah literally it
we recorded in ceno back then and he
literally he was like yeah i'm right
across the street i was like okay you
should have still gotten that plane
ticket
you could have bought a one-way ticket
to anywhere
but then i guess we would have got round
trip it would have been weird if you
asked for a one i ended up back
uh there would have been a way to work
it maybe a voucher i might send a
reimbursement still mm-hmm uh but yeah
so that shit's wild how'd you guys meet
yeah yeah matt and morgan um i work at
the comedy store i'm a dork at the
comedy store morgan's a waitress at the
comedy store
and we we became friends because i asked
him if he played basketball yeah nice
literally that was it
and then we started playing basketball
so you did yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
risky move it was a risky move
[Laughter]
me and they play basketball together too
actually yeah i would love to play more
but you playing two high-level games for
me
yeah no i'm saying like most of the time
the pickup games that you're going to
i'm like
i mean i know i could i could hang out
on the i could be fine on the court but
i don't know if it's a little i want to
get some shots up here i feel like i'm
targeting where do you play yeah we play
with comedians we play with people with
like glasses and stuff the [ __ ] yeah
that's my jam
yeah the last time me and nick played it
was across the street from the studio
balboa park and it was like all like it
was junior high kids basically and nick
was just like
people that and firing them up too they
feel
blocking
ended up fighting each other yes i think
they're frustrated yeah
the frustration was building and we're
like i don't want to see anybody get
stabbed here i feel like we're the only
adults here we might be held responsible
yeah yeah dude you remember that one
time when uh i think it was like one of
the high school breaks and those two
like little kids came in and just shut
the entire school down yeah yeah it was
insane yeah like these two small asian
kids just shooting threes from
everywhere just driving to the basket
yeah they were killing us i bet they
were filipino phillip there's a lot of
short filipino kids who can like they
[ __ ] love basketball i believe cat or
chin said this uh
which is when i was thinking back and i
was like that could have got us canceled
but no one really cares what we say but
that's true you say what you said i
don't want to say it that's one of the
asians
do you remember with the darker asians
oh yeah yeah
i'm serious
the best singers uh
athletes you said the black people of
asians the black people asians yeah so
that's what filipinos are yeah
and i think koreans have the same thing
too because they're really good at
dancing singing all the stuff that you
know culturally that we do the same we
do really well but yeah i used to get
worked at glendale la fitness by some
some short filipinos who could dunk yeah
he can't play at the gyms man it's not
fun
sometimes too intense i like off times
during the day on a weekday you can get
like a regular game in a couple older
guys it won't go up and down the court
that's where i get some easy buckets but
this is manny pacquiao yeah
oh i never seen this clip
terrible shot for him but it's going in
oh he played basketball he's like the
sean marion of the philippines
i want to see a shot could you imagine
playing basketball against manny
pacquiao you like foul him too hard like
you don't want that smoke see is this in
the philippines i feel like these guys
are it's like
it's like when a guy like a kid with
down syndrome goes in a football game
they're just like yeah
score i wonder if they treat him like
putin when he plays hockey yeah that's
what i'm talking about like yeah kid
gloves or uh khadirov he's like this guy
he's the chechnyan uh leader and he
funds a bunch of mma fighters and there
was like a picture of at chemie of like
wrestling him and just like getting
worse by
one of the most ruthless dictators of
our time
good stuff
this does look like our games yeah
a lot of turnovers and fouls is there
anybody is there any names we know that
show up in just [ __ ] school people
no no does rick does rick glassman play
in that game he's really good at best no
it's not good comedy okay
it's not good comics are good basketball
morgan broke his leg and he was a
leading scorer the next week
pretty badly it's like when they carried
paul pierce out and he came back
immediately yeah
wait you said you got hit by a car yeah
i got hit by a car
yes i wasn't previous oh yeah [ __ ] that
prior the easiest one of the easiest
cards to get hit by yeah it was a little
embarrassing that it wasn't
but i'm also happy that it was a prius
yeah yeah
it was like 4am in the morning i was
like crossing the street like santa
monica oh there's fung chow telling me
that only two people and two arms can
come play basketball
i love that guy
that's the leader
we did um
after he got hit we did a episode of our
podcast from the hospital yeah oh [ __ ]
that's i love it's really easy to
especially you guys said you do you
record your podcast with your phones
yeah it's really easy to record remote
podcasts that look and sound fine and i
always think that's fun it's good could
mix it up yeah there was like monitors
beeping in the background [ __ ] at one
point like a nurse walked in yeah it was
it was a lot of time i was there for
like two weeks kind of sucked if your
audience knows you i mean new listeners
might be like i'm gonna turn this off or
do they have a [ __ ]
smoke alarm going off but your listeners
are like oh yeah i get it he's in the
hospital yeah we wanted to show we're
dedicated you know it's like an npr
podcast where they put too many sound
effects
like typing as you transition topics
that was fun though nice episode the
hospital sucked i was i mean the worst
part was i so they're like pumping me
full of like opioids because i'm in a
lot of pain and i couldn't [ __ ] for a
week
that was actually
miserable
yeah does it hurt when you finally do
[ __ ] yeah it felt like no to not [ __ ]
yeah it was terrible i mean i was eating
good food you were bringing me [ __ ] like
week but
i have a pretty
erratic
bathroom
habits i would say i go to the bathroom
quite frequently you got ibs uh yeah i
would say that yeah i think i'm in
denial about denial about some like
lactose intolerance
from wisconsin so that just can't happen
but uh i was i was like looking this up
yesterday i was on the toilet for like
the seventh time and it said like the
range of how frequent people [ __ ] which
is normal
is three to five times a day to once
every three days yeah insane we just
talked about that on our podcast really
yeah it's like it's insane that's a wild
number
where does everybody lie in the spectrum
like i said i am above average seven
times a day but that's a lot different
it's not really seven but i feel like is
it like full poops or like just a little
bit squirts everything everything
everything
sometimes i look and they're just a tiny
piece of food yeah yeah but it felt like
i was like [ __ ]
moving weight i mean when i finally [ __ ]
in the hospital i remember the nurse i
was just sitting there i was like i got
nothing out she looked and she's like no
you did a pretty good job
good amount of people connect your [ __ ]
it's a medical thing that's nasty i
agree
i
quit i would too yeah scroll down you
could see the one from the hospital
browse how often do you poop
did i say like maybe three to five times
a week is that what you said was the
normal range it's a wide range that that
does fall into i would say that's about
once every one to one and a half to two
days yeah so i think i'm on a normal
routine if you're
everything's a normal routine though
yeah it's like seven times a day seems
kind of again above average but
that's crazy that you guys just just
found out you guys miked up too yeah oh
yeah i walked in with like a box of
equipment
that's respectable man you can see my
phone that's recording me like hanging
up against like a ball of lotion
it's a silly time
zoom has these new lives that are like
i don't know there's no
they're just a one piece thing and you
put them on you record it levels out
your voice like cuts out background
noise they're incredible is it what uh
schultz use now because they do labs now
for their podcast yeah they might have i
would assume they have just regular
lives because it sounds a lot better
than regular lives to me yeah maybe
maybe maybe they are but these ones are
like
so you they're for remote recording so
you don't have like a sound board or
like
stuff but they're they're incredible and
uh
that's some [ __ ] nerdy possibility
about it
i do a podcast with two other guys don't
do that and
uh another podcast show thanks brother
what's your album called uh well i got a
new single dropping called arizona but
we just listened on uh king in the sting
today actually we went out
arizona
and a baddie yeah who might be an
alcoholic
should we we'll listen to it in uh one
second but i feel like i had a point
that i was almost wrapping up your
podcast with you guys oh mike's uh i do
like the mic because we talk we all want
to talk the whole time and just to grab
of the mic is signals yeah
without without
so yeah that it's utilitarian
um anybody see elvis
is that already i don't know it might be
this week come on i think it is this
week oh okay yeah i'm gonna go see it i
want to see it i like it
he's a good director oh i was like is
that is that who plays elvis because i
don't know the guy
austin butler
where else you been in anything
i don't know i've just been seeing him
pop up lately and this girl i went to
dinner with was talking about him and
timothy chalamet so i feel like they're
the two play boys in hollywood right now
and i feel like timothy they
there are just these people that get
picked because timothy he's been around
now for years but all of a sudden he was
just like
he's like every heartthrob i'm like he's
like little and i don't know he doesn't
seem like a i don't know if the kids are
attractive anymore yeah back in our day
we have proper movie stars goddamn right
yeah timothy
uh like he's an actor though i guess
elvis boy he was texan once upon a time
in hollywood
with the charles manson group
tex watson oh yeah you remember that
yeah and now i kind of see where you're
going but i want to hear this thought
completed why do you feel bad for john
travolta oh because i feel like this
movie should have been made years ago
and this guy every time i see the
trailer he just looks like john travolta
to me
it's like john travolta should have got
this like in the 90s who are we waiting
for to make the elvis movie they could
have put him in like a fat suit and had
him be like old elvis yeah yeah that
would be nice actually he is fat now
right john travolta is he i think so i
think he's one of the fat guys
i mean he's like what 60 yeah yeah you
just get fat when you get old but
the reason i brought it up or actually
i was thinking about the elvis movie and
it like had i had like an epiphany about
this movie i hadn't thought about since
childhood
uh and i'm excited to hear if any of you
guys have seen it
or heard of it rock rock-a-doodle
no
it's a uh animated movie from 1992 where
a rooster is like the biggest deal on
the farm because he's the reason that
the sun comes up every day
this does look familiar but on a day
where there's a loon or a solar eclipse
they're like oh you don't make the sun
come out because he like crowed and he
got like shamed and he left the farm for
vegas
and he became elvis essentially
yeah and then and then he dated this
pheasant who was like a vegas showgirl
on the pheasant like i was five or maybe
like four and she like
aroused me and said look at that chicken
so not one see i feel like i made this
movie up except for the fact that he
found the movie poster yeah has anybody
seen rock a doodle no she's banging the
movie poster looks familiar but i don't
remember this at all it's uh it's it's
quite the trip and to me that's the real
elvis biopic
it wasn't black people he stole from
it's the [ __ ] chicken
the crushes the the animated crushes
like the um bunny from
the bottom
well it was a bear in the goo or no are
they dogs but i know who you're talking
about she was a bunny i think and what
what are you talking about you're
talking about space jam right oh yeah
yeah yeah that too in a goofy movie
goofy movie that was a dog and she was
fine oh yeah yeah she was fine what the
she was like 12. i was 12. it's not
weird oh yeah okay
i don't think she's fine now i don't
remember the girl from them
oh yeah i do remember yeah oh yeah yeah
she's cute
she wasn't hot like lola bunnies no big
like girl next door vibes yeah yeah you
could bring her home to mom well not a
goofy movie
and then in space jam 2 they didn't like
the sexualization of cartoons so they
made lola a lesbian yeah i think
they took away and gave her super baggy
shorts
that movie was like too well done it
sucked the new space jam that's a
different that's a different way i would
describe it but i also didn't like it
it was like two like new age just modern
it was so clean but it stunk yeah yeah i
mean did you guys see the new lion king
yeah like took out all the good parts
yeah yeah they took out all the funny
parts it just yeah it just sucks now
there she is
do you guys have back then and we can go
around the room if you don't have one
that's fine but do you guys have any
movies like this that like
you just haven't thought about in a
while
anybody i mean i've thought about it
recently because it's on like stars and
you do podcasts and you need like true
to talk about yeah
it's just a movie about kids going to
school in the morning but all this zany
[ __ ] happens before like they even get
on the road isn't it
tim arnold
oh i love tom arnold have you guys seen
the stupids
the stupids there there's a book called
the stupids and it was about a family
that was this is another one i just
thought of that family stupid yeah
stanley stupid and they've they
yes
it was a cartoon book it's basically
like if they made like amelia bedelia a
real uh movie and
tom arnold was mr stupid dude and they
were such a dumb family they did all
these stupid things
stupid yes well the alien was like
stanley stupid hey and they basically
think their garbage is being stolen
every week and they want to uncover this
conspiracy about who's stealing your
garbage
yeah are so great it's just like the
family's stupid in their conspiracy the
stupids has there been a amelia bedelia
movie
i
what's amelia bedelia i have no idea oh
she's just like a girl who takes
everything literally
like the so she's like a maid and
they'll be like oh yeah so we're going
to be off like do the laundry draw the
curtains and then she'll come back and
she's like i drew the curtains but just
like a dumb blonde essentially it's a
children's book that's like 20 pages at
a time i'm so good though
she was so dumb
she had like a mental issue obviously
but they didn't care back then she's
really
yeah well yeah
yeah i actually commend that family for
employing people especially
they got a taxes actually
yeah she played a baseball game and they
were like steel home and so she took
home and left you know yeah yeah yeah
she's great and she's super gangly i
think of her like this
carpool fire carpool is so so good yeah
the stupas i feel like around that time
i was watching coneheads
remember that movie yeah yeah
saturday live yeah
and the movie which i didn't see but
blank check was my favorite movie
playing check that as a banger
i was like my favorite show
now i i don't want like
it is kind of a subjective game but i
would say that doesn't count everybody
thinks of blank check all the time
that was just my that was my [ __ ] that's
not good yes ending but
i don't think oh that's the guy now man
he he filled out the wrong blank check
he got caught up with him
damn he bought meth with that money yeah
that's rough [ __ ] a bicycle that's a
tough tattoo to have on your neck too
colorful butterfly off-screen that's
right
his head looks off center yeah
uh
you guys i'm sure have seen uh the
before and afters and he's doing well
now but of goldberg from them yeah
i tried to get him on theo's podcast for
a while because like addiction and
recovery and he was like doing well but
uh he has some weird handler dude who's
like yikes trying to make it about him
but he was just recently on the adam
carolla show and he he's doing well berg
and it's crazy to go from being the fat
kid to being that dude ben stiller would
be so proud
he goes
he goes from hiding all that candy to
look at him
never give up oh
step on the scale son
look at that he's so funny
creamy here
i don't understand what happens to your
body when you start doing meth that like
your face gets off
wait what's on the left they put them
filter yeah that is him whoa that's like
the old
macbook filter
how old does he get that anymore
um probably in his early 40s when did
that movie come out
in the 90s early 90s maybe
he was born in 87.
so oh [ __ ] she's like 35. here are some
of the answers from he looks like that
yeah bro nothing's bad for you
some of the uh cats after dark instagram
followers
spirited away
oh that's scary what is it it's an anime
no but that's like universally
we were talking about this like maybe a
month ago you guys ever seen house
arrest
no
so uh the premise is like this kid's
parents are getting divorced somebody
locks them in the basement and like
tries to make them like work their [ __ ]
out but then like people out of school
find out they're like my parents are
[ __ ] up too so they keep bringing
parents over
it's wild it's good jennifer love hewitt
jamie lee curtis yeah
that first kid is like
i don't know he grew up to be a deranged
adult
you can't be doing that
what about the explorers you guys
remember the explorers
i think brandon lee or something
phoenix one of the younger brothers
that's dead in this room we may not be
like oh yeah i can't wait to see
explorer but like there's a couple
people at home where we just like lost
their [ __ ] yeah
so good
they go to space and like a thing they
built just as kids and they meet a crazy
alien river is the dead one yeah river's
the ethan hawk still a lot
ethan hawk's like a g
listen to his interviews i i was i was
didn't doubt you but i was like why just
like he's just a smart guy does he have
a new movie out black phone or something
is that him yeah oh is it him yeah
yeah i love ethan hawk he did some movie
where um
he finds
like a dumpster baby essentially or
something and it's like an independent
film
and then
he like takes off with it and he like it
helps him get his life together because
he was homeless or something i don't
know the exact premise but the baby is
like
my good buddy from high school who i
live with when i went out to l.a it's
his nephews they're twins they're twins
adopt a highway
yes
is the baby a highway i know that baby
i know that baby
thank you
it's actually two babies how old are
they now were they twins child yeah laws
yeah right is that crazy
we're friends but we don't necessarily
support each other's content
he's the listener see those are the best
kind of friends
subscribe to another podcast network i
don't know yeah yeah i don't he doesn't
watch after dark yeah he's a huge morgan
myself might watch this episode oh yeah
we're going after the youth
yeah
killing it
uh
what else guys
i don't know like mom and dad save the
world you ever seen that oh we don't
have to keep talking about this topic
you guys remember camp nowhere
no it was about like all these kids and
their parents were sending them to camp
for the summer and uh they all go to
like different camps but they don't
actually want to go to camps and they
find like this old homeless dude and uh
he just takes all their money just buys
them a bunch of [ __ ] like whatever they
want and then it's like parents visiting
day so they actually have to like
pretend that they were at like these
camps love that no parents no counselors
no rules yeah dude i just realized like
what christopher lloyd i qualify as an
acceptable answer is whether or not i've
heard of the movie
you know movies i wonder if they hold up
is mr b
i think so
dude
yeah i think so yeah he he's like a
modern-day charlie chaplin yeah yeah so
slapstick he's the man
yeah
chen do you got one nostalgic i do um do
you guys remember the gate
one of these movies from 1943 no
it was in the 80s it was like a
two kids in their backyard
had like this hole it was freaking
awesome
it's like sci-fi [ __ ] yeah it's like a
kind of horror sci-fi but it was fun it
was kind of gnarly it's like an
adventure movie when you're in the hell
yeah it's kind of basically the gay tale
what's the one with howie mandel that
looks like this
under the bed oh yeah and with uh kevin
kevin from wonder yours is that
uh fred savage yeah fred savage was that
one
izzy you go little monsters little
monsters yeah
and just every movie he does the same
voice
uh fred savage are holding it up holly
mandel the uh the bobby from bobby's
world voice
he also did um
in muppet babies he was uh gizmo
was he mm-hmm it's the same voice you
hear him and bobby back-to-back
bobby's always amazing great show yeah
and it was always back-to-back with
louie may he rest in peace
do you guys remember
the 13th year disney movie yeah the
mermaid oh yeah the mermaid that was a
great one
disney had a nice little run for a while
they had that they had smart house
what did we watch recently there was
eddie's uh
eddie's cookoff was a good one brink was
just the word word and i thought of team
puppets what's the one where it's kind
of like brink
um there's like it's like hockey johnny
tsunami johnny johnny
triple axel
i don't know it's like the slap shot is
like the tagline in there he's got like
playing hockey but the dude's like a
surfer
this isn't the one that you're thinking
of but lucky the irish was another oh is
that the one with the two twins
uh no that is double team double team
yeah she does like the worst move ever
at the end of the game she just like
pumps her feet back and forth
right but look at the irish might be one
of the best look at the others i was a
huge bastard i yeah i just did a ranking
of the best basketball and i forgot
like a [ __ ] idiot yeah that guy was
scary as [ __ ] basketball diaries did you
put that on there i didn't it's
fire that's a really good movie man i
didn't have disney growing up i missed
all of these
my basketball movies yeah space jam he
got game above the rim
uh
uh i can't jump white man can't jump it
was my number one
the best one
what hoosiers coach coach carter coach
carter [ __ ] sucks that fake ass
remember the titans get the [ __ ] out of
here
it's i know that's they just started a
movie there's no racial tension in coach
carter well not to the end it's a
similar movie
i didn't finish the movie worm dude
he like made me cringe like how hard he
tried to act in that movie i really
liked him in old school he's the guy
with the the the light skin guy with the
throat right yeah yeah
yeah i wasn't buying it he gave such a
good speech though
uh did you guys see hustle with adam
sandler yeah i enjoyed it a lot it was
great it was great
i didn't like the idea of a uh
there being some spanish 610 guy who is
some hidden gem basketball player that
no one's ever just working at the
factory yeah yeah bro you're tall in the
whole country i think they figured out
what to do i think they won gold in the
olympics
they're gonna find their homegrown
talent oh they should have been the
sudan yeah juan hernan gomez
he's an actual basketball player
anthony edwards pretty decent actor yeah
he was good he was good
i want to see that it's great i love
adam sandler
i like what he
he got super popular so then they gave
him a production company and then he
just like made all these shitty movies
that like had to be green lit by by
studios that didn't work but now he's so
popular he's just like i'm gonna make
[ __ ] i like like
he made a billion dollars and got all
his friends rich yeah yeah i didn't mean
all the shitty movies did well yeah
they're yeah yeah made money yeah
and in i i said this recently on
something but like
come on
in uh jack and jill the movie which i
think is like when people think of like
bad adam sandler movies that's the one
that like springs to mind but in the
movie in the beginning in the 10 minutes
he's like he's a movie producer and he's
talking to someone he's like imagine
this i got 500 people depending on me
you got to keep putting [ __ ] out and
he's like i felt like he was like
confessing what he was going through
right but now he's like made it and
everybody's [ __ ] feeling it there's
like a viral clip it came by facebook
watch but they're being interviewed at a
table
in like 1997 just out to eat and it's
like
i don't know some like mtv vj woman
who's like hot interviewing them okay it
might be brick shields actually
not an empty
her by the way with uh was that movie
she was in like her first movie
uh blue lagoon yes she was like the og
like hot woman that's a good answer and
i have seen it
i'll accept it but uh and they're
talking about at this dinner like we
just want to make stuff we like and hang
out and that's the dream and it's like
oh jesus christ they that's
what they did wait i'm a hug you you
said you saw this on facebook yeah
facebook still using that facebook watch
i'm in a lot of facebook groups below
deck related facebook groups i mean 22
below deck facebook
uh yeah yeah i have the number one below
deck recap podcast in the world i don't
know
definitively actually they're starting
to spring up when we started there
weren't many there were some bravo
general ones but now we got a lot of
competition and we squashed them and
yeah it's like a big good yeah it's a
huge show it's a big show it was like
we we did the bachelor first and it got
a little
i don't know traction but there was so
much competition but then below deck
we're like oh a lot of people watching
it but now it just keeps growing and
they keep doing spin-offs it's [ __ ]
incredible it's probably one of the
biggest tv franchises that i've never
seen an episode of watch it it's awesome
did you like real world back in the day
oh yeah i feel like it's like real world
but there's also this added wrinkle of
rich people coming on the boat every
three days and then like kind of
[ __ ] up there
yeah it's good [ __ ]
you think needs to pee or something uh i
don't know what the [ __ ] this problem is
here's how long we've been going this is
a good pod i just need topics
[Laughter]
anybody want to talk about anything
let's talk i'll cut out the awkward
parts let's talk about how [ __ ]
jewels got banned today [ __ ] yeah news
with yours
they're illegal or you just can't buy
them
so today's action is further progressed
on the fda's commitment to ensuring that
all e-cigarettes in the elect electronic
nicotine delivery system blah blah blah
they're yeah they're just trying to ban
all type of [ __ ] e-cigarettes i'm
pretty sure
dude don't make me go back to cigarettes
i know right like [ __ ]
i don't want to do that it smells food
doesn't taste as good
oh yeah dude i'm [ __ ] i mean i got the
door right here yeah i got yeah well i'm
on the phone now it's illegal these are
i like these they'll put it on camera
yeah so apparently the fda did not
receive uh all the correct clinical
information that they wanted to to prove
that these devices aren't hurting us i
guess but i mean what like what do you
[ __ ] want us to do of course they're
hurting us yeah
there was like a thing like a year and a
half ago about like jewels and like kids
like just dying spontaneously and i
really think it's just big tobacco and
yeah mm-hmm what's it called
more pharma
morris
oh philippe morse yeah i it's just it's
just them being like what's the eight i
think i made that there were an initial
from that yeah i didn't know the a
either
i don't think it exists i was like
joseph didn't even question it
trying to sound more distinguished
i thought that big tobacco made jewel
i think it's less regulated than like
any company can have like i don't think
jewel is owned by phil
i don't know that for a fact i know big
tobacco they're the ones that make like
the commercials where it's like vaping
so much worse for you
they're still trying to push cigarettes
give it up dog
it's over i mean they're still crushing
people still smoking go in the digital
world yeah but way more people vape
we just used like a newport branded vape
they got him
why'd you look at him when you said that
i accept a pack of new ports on my
dresser
just in case just overall
like break the glass emergency you never
know you want some new ports and e and j
before the uh
next one
let's talk about magic mind oh
magic mine we don't have any oh
uh but that's why we're so sluggish
today even though we haven't been like i
said this is a good pop i was so looking
forward to it yeah that's my favorite
drink i guess maybe you guys won't quit
come back one shot of magic mind every
episode for you guys
but uh magic mind is a once daily shot i
think of it as the anti-procrastination
drink you've been taking it how has it
helped your life i feel so focused and
so alert i loved it so much i made a
whole song for it actually
oh
sing it
is it on your youtube
it was uh we just made it not too long
ago is it on your youtube it's on
someone's instagram right it's on magic
might put it out we did like a collab
with it and stuff
ins uh magic mine instagram you actually
have to hear the song it's a banger uh
but it tells a little bit about some of
the the 12 natural ingredients there in
magic mind it if you guys want to try to
go magic mind dot co slash dark use
promo code dark for 25 off uh the uh
the ceo and founder of magic mind is my
close friend and confidant james bashira
and he once he basically went to the
hospital because he was drinking like 20
cups of coffee a day when he started
some company that he eventually sold to
airbnb and they're like you need to stop
drinking coffee and he's like i'm an
addict what do i do and then he
he sold that company he started magic
mind and this is his new venture and he
works like eight hours a day on and he
sold two million bottles of magic mind
yeah wow we probably sold like
140 of those
numbers
this is your song it is for magic
magic mind about to make the whole day
everyone sluggish
that shot took eight days
i was like
i was like i don't want to be
responsible
wait what do you mix it with
uh some people you we can drink it
straight but that was like oatmeal yeah
you can mix it with oat milk uh even in
your coffee some people do it okay some
people put it in perrier
[Music]
great video yeah he didn't quit he got
cancelled
what's that this one yeah you know
that's fake though is it yeah 4chan
started that to be funny but then
it became like a real thing
it's the perfect it's the perfect game
yeah you're right that's annoying let us
we're gonna keep it it's been okay
forever yeah yeah
george you done any open mics lately
yeah yesterday after work i hit the
fourth wall in noho
it was like all right like mike you can
kind of like know like the energy going
into it and i was just like uh this
probably isn't gonna go that well i
don't know but it was fine i he talked
to him i'm sure you cut your teeth on
all
the mics you know yeah but when i was
doing it it was free
i didn't have to do the [ __ ] slotted
[ __ ] yeah they ruined open my comedy in
l.a man yeah
when did you start
um i moved to l.a in like 2006 summer
2016.
that was like actually when i tried i
maybe did like 30 open mics but it just
really yeah it felt like not worth the
time for like to kill a whole night
at all but then how do you how do you
get reps if it's
i mean i got lucky and just got up at
the store and got a job there it's like
you you don't know how you do it without
that you hit like the potluck and you
did well yeah and i had friends that
worked there that recommended me i mean
derrick was like a big guy in my corner
and
yeah just kind of help me out so
i don't know how you just go through the
mic scene and get any success i think
you would just have to push it online
and hope it catches but comfortability
on stage i would say it was for sure you
got to become a good comment
yeah it's important yeah
but do you have tick-tock
i mean if you see some of the people
posting to tick-tock they're not good
yeah they get numbers so it's like
yeah so even bad mics you can get
something out of it and walk away with
it like
i recorded every single one and it was
like looked back i listened back like i
was kind of brutal but then you kind of
hear like little things and it's like it
helps it's good you do that yeah how
long you been at it
i started two years ago in new york but
then kind of covet interrupted a little
bit
um and i was doing like outdoor mics
because i moved back to l.a once coveted
hit
and then i moved to croatia for like 10
months so i didn't do anything so like
on and off for two and a half years good
mike scene in croatia no no no not at
all
not at all yeah i mean mike's in la is
mostly just to meet people and yeah
figure out who your friend group is
going to be
yeah i was like i don't like any of you
yeah they started doing this thing where
you just pay five dollars and there's
only what like 10 people or whatever
yeah like the most i used to go to work
at bars and you'd have to buy a drink
but you'd get a drink that was like yeah
in new york the mics i would do in new
york it was kind of more like that like
go like it wasn't five bucks it was buy
a drink and then you get time and put
your name in the hat now it's like you
have to sign up like hours before
unslotted and
hope there's still space and i'd rather
give money and support a business than
some [ __ ] person scamming open
microphones yeah it's like yeah i don't
know
because there's like multiple places
that do that now right fourth wall and
birthday like i don't know if that still
exists but i don't think that place is
around but i feel like most places i go
to i sign up on slotted before yeah and
i really like the fourth wall like all
the places i go but it's just like
i i didn't like in new york you just it
was like more barry and like i don't
know not so structured i feel like you
just hop in and it's like what's the
pipeline from that uh you start scamming
open micros then you eventually graduate
to bring her shows
yeah well you just get rich that's a
good point i mean the girl started
bird's background was making like 100k a
year excuse me she started what not open
my curse for real group yeah i mean we
did the math i don't know how much he
was actually making but
you know
when you run 12 hours a day you get 50
an hour
there is you don't pay anybody you pay
rent there was like jesus oh i guess 12
hours could start at like two and go to
two yeah but like yeah that's some early
afternoon comedy and people were stupid
and there was was there audience members
or was it all no so it's the 10 people
that are on the show you have to go and
you have to stay for the hour you're
slotted for gotcha and watch
and pay for it and pay for it [ __ ] yeah
i probably i probably went to a couple
of
i have a question for these guys yeah
really um that's dope so the pot luck
how does it i just i i had known about
i've never like submitted for it before
last week and then i didn't get it but i
was like oh i would still want to go and
like check it out and it was sold out
like like i wasn't expecting like um
on instagram yeah email luke schwartz
[Laughter]
it was a lottery crazy yeah but so it's
not like like people actually go and
watch it it's not just like comics
sitting like
yeah i didn't know i went up there it
was like or went on the website and it's
like oh i'll just like go to the to the
mic and hit me up next time okay yeah
i'll take care of you for sure before i
before i moved to la i did one open mic
in minneapolis acme and they have like
an awesome like
it's like a tradition their monday open
mic because it's like
six days a week it's actually a touring
comic coming to town but the monday open
mic
god damn it
i mean sometimes he's chill sometimes
he's not i don't know he pooped right
before i don't know what he wants
god damn he needs a rain we do need
christian here
[Laughter]
open mic was awesome they they would
like it was free to come but to drink
minimum and it would fill out would be
300 people
and they'd do 20 comics in a row but
like you said they always said it was
lottery and then like
the higher you got in the lottery then
you did more time towards the end but
suspiciously it was always the same
people and i feel like it shouldn't be
like that yeah on your way on yeah no
one wants 15 minutes of uh
me
this is my first time
i started in san diego and the mic i
started out was kind of like that where
it was full every week and that's the
only mic i did for like a year
and so i would hear people talk about
like how hard stand-up is and how you
bomb all the time and [ __ ] and i was
like i must be a [ __ ] prodigy though
dude i was like i'm killing every single
week dude i was like i'm gonna quit my
job and live in my car in l.a
and i did
it wasn't because i did well at the open
mic but i was like that that didn't hurt
can we hear any of your bits uh
i'll i'll say the first thing that uh i
said on stage because i won't i'm gonna
do stand up again because
if you have a [ __ ] if you ever get a
following then you like yeah it's such
easy money
even a hundred people you put on your
own show like i mean you can make some
decent money so morgan you have to do
standards yeah for sure because you're i
think your guys podcast is going to pop
off please shut up
he's having a good time with the boys
yeah there's the boys chilling
so i would i would go up on stage i'd
say
one time
i went to dumb and dumber two
in theaters
by myself
on christmas
in the theater with me
were five other people
all
also
by themselves
and i looked around and i was like
man
no matter how lonely you feel
you can still judge other people
because these people must be huge pieces
of [ __ ] to be here on christmas by
themselves and it did okay and then i
had nothing after that but that was a
real story of when i was in la in my car
i eventually had a christmas dinner with
a friend actually the [ __ ] the uncle
of that baby
uh but uh
do you remember that matthew mcconaughey
movie the beach bum
is he sleeping on people's couch yeah
he's like a rider in like key west or
something like a drunk and like a
pothead but it's not that good but i
went to go see it by myself at like a 10
30 show and it was me and one other guy
in the theater and he sat like two seats
next to me
the whole time's like this guy is for
sure going to stab me yeah like so then
but he's probably thinking the same
thing about me too things like that is
this crazy person watching beach bomb at
10 30 by themselves on tuesday what year
was this like 2019 it's like right
before the panda oh that guy was like a
youtuber or something he's like i'm
gonna go sit by someone just by
themselves
eating by yourself movies by yourself
all about it yeah put on the headphones
yeah everybody smoke by myself drink by
myself [ __ ] these hoes by my goddamn i'm
a goddamn self
i don't know if you were lonely or you
just had it all figured out yeah that's
true it was dumb and dumber too though
that's how you know i didn't oh it was a
second run movie theater i paid two
dollars in pasadena that's still too
much for that movie oh yeah
it's so
bad
really so bad and so is a dumb and
dumber
er wait no that wasn't the same
was the one i saw in theaters dumb and
dumber error was the sequel that didn't
have them but that was also very bad
oh i was thinking of dumb and dumber
yeah with bob saget yeah yeah yeah
this wasn't good either though i didn't
see this oh it's so bad i didn't see
this it was just like trying to
recapture the magic and doing the same
jokes but they looked really old every
time they take too long i remember when
i saw anchorman too and i was so
disappointed yeah it was my fault dude
yeah it's like the greatest comedy of
all time it's
at least quote quotable for sure like
you can pull out a million zoolander two
did you see that
also i slept with that movie so i was
about to ask was that an actual movie or
did i make that up in my head no two
letter two exists
we watched the second one or the first
one like two three weeks ago so [ __ ]
funny i saw zoolander 2 in theaters with
like a group of like 15 comics and it
was still not fun at all
i don't remember this at all it's so bad
i i never saw that this might be worse
than dumb and dumber
that makes me that makes me i don't
think i've ever watched the even because
i like i learned my lesson but i love
the first zoolander so yeah it's
incredible
um i i think that's a pretty solid show
uh what what's everybody doing what what
do you want to plug
we'll start with matt watch our podcast
big humble tick tock youtube
um instagram we don't really
i'm big he's humble don't show don't
show the instagram
um
um
on youtube subscribe to us on youtube so
we can monetize yeah yeah it'll be nice
um definitive rankings of everything
coming back soon i don't know just
follow us on instagram what's this come
out you guys show on monday tomorrow
and handsome morgan yeah handsome
underscore morgan uh culture court too
culture court at the comedy store the
last monday of every month it's a really
fun show
it's wild yes it's an insane show i just
saw a picture on your instagram and
you're wearing like a powdered wig
what's what what's the premise me and
this guy keith johnson another very
funny comic um we come out as judges we
have two jurors who are just like the
two best comics on the show and then we
solve cases so we have people come up
that want to sue each other or sue like
an idea or
um like we have personal cases or like
this one we're
it's like the the united states versus
florida to see if they should secede we
have a representative from florida and a
representative from the u.s and it's
just like a wild show we say crazy [ __ ]
crazy things happen
you know the people
generally who are in disputes or is it
like people submit ideas and you're like
we'll take that one kind of both um we
like know people that
yeah are having issues and will be like
if you want to solve this we'll we'll do
it um but we also reach out to people
and like hey we have a case idea for you
kind of stuff like that i want to get
into dispute with someone
yeah if you ever have anything let me
know yeah for sure
but it's a crazy shirt it's a lot of fun
the last one ended with like a freestyle
rap battle yeah it was the second one
ended with a dance off with two
beautiful black men
yeah one and a half speedos
oh yeah i was looking at malik
rob smallwood is yeah he's kind of
not that beautiful but no he's beautiful
he's just short yeah i'm gonna have to
bleep that name now yeah
uh
you can finally go against [ __ ]
corey and court or [ __ ] corey feldman
i need to get that video out there it's
[ __ ] why what's your beaver corey
feldman um
it's it's a whole thing but
this is real
he put out his love locked down 2.1 box
set he charged 369
two weeks later he bumps down the price
to 222 dollars i was tweeting at him i
was like why would you punish the fans
who went out there and bought it first
day he blocked me so then i went to his
concert at the whiskey of gogo on 222
the day that corey feldman died i really
jammed out the show got to talk to him
later he assuaged my fears but they
didn't reach out like they said they
were going to
but this was me talking to the venue of
uh just finding out some stuff and i
made a new friend wait so you're like a
you're a genuine huge fan of corey
feldman
i don't have the confidence to stay in
it and just say yes i am and i should
turn up
are most encounters legit are they like
these washed up aspects you need a
paycheck
he was talking about like a fantasy camp
they do it a whiskey a go-go where
nickelback comes and teaches people how
to i'm in oh yeah that sounds amazing
[Music]
i i was trying to find out what time
corey would be on stage
we talked for 11 minutes
that's crazy i will take this case and
defend corey feldman yeah we started
talking about vaccinations
it was an up and down conversation i
think he wanted to bet me if i'm going
to be honest is dead
no cory uh
yeah yeah yeah i'll be honest i respect
that one running up on the people who've
wronged you
i like you taking it to this extent oh
yeah yeah there's a good whole
documentary finding corey
mitch mcconnell we're coming for you too
bro it's it's way late
mitch mcconnell
uh i don't know careful he's one of my
heroes i don't
i
i think everybody should take care of
themselves i don't really have political
beliefs so my podcast co-host really
hates mitch mcconnell and we're trying
to get him to fight him in a celebrity
boxing
match no way that happened
whatever
not with that attitude
getting in a ring whether you think you
can or whether you think you can't
you're right mitch mcconnell was too
much of a [ __ ] ever getting a ring with
anybody they don't call him the hammer
for nothing
that was the line from the letter i
wrote to him which is my favorite line
uh if you get it i like you more jen
where can we find you um
so actually i'm doing a t
t-shirt collab i think until yeah
yeah so i'm doing a t-shirt every
episode yeah
but yeah
the design is finalized now so they're
just going to get get into production so
just follow my instagram chinsuyi and
then uh
you'll see when the design gets out and
hopefully you guys all buy it and um
what else does it say on my youtube
channel i'm giving away 275 gift cards
to into the end just go there watch the
last video
that's it you got free shirts for us
i've got dude i'm gonna hook up everyone
hell yeah yeah if you guys like into
them it's really good quality yeah
i like shirts cool yeah i just like free
[ __ ]
george's we have uh there's a new
podcast coming uh through thick boy
studios it's gonna be on extra thick
youtube channel but it's uh 12 packs
with jeff dye and we open up training or
trading cards and drink beer and it's
super dope super fun and i think uh i
think we're gonna put the first one up
on saturday so check that out
my apology that's the intro
we flew jeff die all the way out
from sherman oaks
but yeah we got that
i was wondering i saw the stories i was
like when does this come out yeah yeah
i think mike's done editing it i'm gonna
do a little sizzle today and tomorrow
and saturday should be fun [ __ ] yeah
other george
uh you can catch me
on my youtube go george go i put out a
new vlog
of me opening a one-of-one volkanovsky
ufc card only one that exists i've met
brian chappelle and kat for the first
time in this vlog so
fun times so yeah my instagram and my
youtube cool
nice go george go hell yeah thank you
thank you do you have a like pigtails in
that picture yeah i have like [ __ ]
post malone braids going so i'm into
that yeah that's dope
that's a good look oh all right yeah
did you actually have those braids at
one point or was it yeah creative it was
like i don't do it often because i don't
don't be honest every day
i think you should though that's a good
look
i'm a fan i like this look better what
are you are you white yeah yeah it's
even i'm usually against one
you're pulling it off thank you thank
you
uh check out and
i didn't want to always like put myself
last like i was the most important so i
was gonna go but then i was worried that
you would think you didn't get yours in
no you go yeah you go another podcast
show check it out uh
we're fighting mitch mcconnell we're
finding corey feldman
we're honoring corey haim another
podcast show
that's actually a great not a bad
tagline yeah pretty good rule of threes
where can they find you find me on
instagram at low brows got a new song
coming out called arizona featuring
austin awake who was on the last cast
after dark and um yeah pre-saves
available soon so
run that up for your boy
[ __ ] yeah what did your name come from
um yes
podcast yeah from brendan yeah
because he has big brows all right but
they called them little your hair is
high enough so we can't even see you
yeah look at those bad boys oh yeah
they're caterpillars
those are good
those are good we could change the name
to this podcast to caterpillars i got it
i shave mine with it too and they
[ __ ] come back everywhere
i'll be honest
all around dude it's so easy
giving them a fade
put a nice taper on your [ __ ] face
one day i'm gonna be startled and i'm
gonna come in with one
all right that's it cats after dark
[Music]
[Music]
foreign